o compositor produtor e intérprete e
multi instrumentista foi na música que o
seu trabalho é atingir
nacional mas tem igual paixão e glória
tem imagem é realizador produtor e
editor de muitos dos seus telediscos e
das fotografias que acompanham a sua
carreira
davi fonseca hora ou outra eu não estava
assim em palco é o sistema que estava é
mais fácil com a guitarra tenho sede da
garrafa tem essa coisa dos quais já que
agradecer o facto de terem convidado
para passar daqui porque eu estou
cumprindo os meus sonhos mais antigos
que ter um destino cruel fóruns em que
não time que está num sítio com o tripé
para que possa acho que a grande
vantagem se ia poder dançar aqui o crime
à frente todos vocês mas vou poupar
mesmo embaraço é bom ter essa fotografia
quer dizer que quando quando fui
convidado para falar aqui é é a primeira
coisa que eu pensei foi de raiva eu
falar que eu lembrei me de uma de uma
aula que eu tive na escola de cinema é
há muitos anos atrás era o mal havia
argumentos onde tínhamos que ver esse
caneco se inscreveram se standard
convênio experiência com isso é
maravilhosa que me escreveram uma curta
metragem e quando cheguei à sala a todos
os alunos inscritos
esta curta metragem e o professor antes
de ler qualquer uma destas curtas
metragens não perguntou aos 15 alunos
estavam na sala
quantos nós tinham morto alguém aí na
nossa história assassinado alguém e
todos levantaram o braço eu eu fiquei
surpreendido é o professor não e eu
pergunto quanto nós já tenha
efetivamente visto alguém ser
assassinada tivesse especial nessa
instrumento é claro nenhum de nós tinha
visto ninguém
ovar com um tiro o meu era contínuo
e eu disse então por favor levem de
volta às vossas argumentos queria
mostrar alguma coisa possa efetivamente
saiba sombra é isso foi uma foi uma
lição que eu nunca mais esquece e que o
trouxe para que presta na conversa é
porque achei que talvez o melhor fosse
falar sobre uma coisa que eu soubesse
alguma coisa sobre e e pronto eu sei
algumas coisas sobre a minha pessoa não
quer ser vaidosa mas não falaram que
querem sobre o meu percurso é uma das
perguntas que mais não fazem ao longo
dos anos quando eu ando na estrada
quando o clínico tomava há muitos
músicos vêm ter comigo música jovens
muitos de vós ir a alguma alguma idade
está aqui consegue muitas pessoas com 15
saiu aos 70 anos e que perguntam várias
vezes diversas formas como atingir o
sucesso no mundo da música e eu acho que
a pergunta mais estranha que o podem
fazer porque pra ele não fazer porque eu
acho que eu saí eu não sei como atingir
o sucesso da casa mas me intriga muito e
pergunta por que alguém 15 ou 16 anos
está tão preocupado em atingir o sucesso
que o que mais
talvez me intriga porque o sucesso
porque é que esta é porque isto moto do
pensamento e algo que quer apenas
criativa
eu acho que perceberam que digo isso eu
tenho que pensar um bocadinho atrás
também tenho que pensar efetivamente o
que é que eu era quando tinha 15 ou 16
anos e por isso é que vemos aqui é que
não aqui e sou eu
com 15 anos numa numa fotografia que é
claramente pousada não é onde claramente
a minha vaidade dos 15 anos
eu não sei andar mota o mota não
funciona
aquela camiseta foi investido
especificamente esta fotografia e que o
penteado também foi feito
especificamente para esta fotografia
eu não sei que eu pretendia com isto não
faça liberdade não temos 30 afi a
ninguém
era uma miúda que eu quisesse
impressionar no campus trair ninguém
gostar de vocês para o embaraço
felizmente a mota sobrevivo foi todo
mutilado e hoje funciona mas outra coisa
falou nesta fotografia que eu gosto é o
facto de eu ter folhas no sapato
se eu usava roupas os sapatos continha
15 anos porque vi numa revista inglesa
os tipos da boys band usarem nem por
isso achei que também era bom pra mim
altura tal como todos os miúdos que
perguntou sobre o sucesso eu não fazia a
mínima ideia sobre o que eu ia fazer a
minha vida eu não tinha em um plano eu
não não fazia ia ser músico
ok ser o que quer que fosse eu não tinha
qualquer ideia sobre o futuro nesta
altura eu era com qualquer mills 15 anos
vaidoso a tirar fotografias e cinco
portas velhas e uma um dia específico
uma semana específica que usou um cabo
esta minha é essa minha estadia num
estado mental tão tão vazia o típico de
um centro não é onde não sei muito bem o
que é o futuro nem sequer me preocupava
tanto com isso
até que os meus pais foram visitar um
estilo é e disseram que eu tinha que
estar à altura em que eu não mandava na
minha própria vontade e eu fui com os
meus pais carro e sabia que ser uma
viagem perigosa porque obviamente última
coisa que uma de um jovem de 15 anos
quer passado uma semana inteira com os
pais dentro de um carro e eu fui com o
irmão nesta viagem eo vai isto esta
máquina é uma máquina que os meus pais
tinham uma gaveta lá em casa
insta matic 233 da codeca
esta máquina eu não sei quem é que
comprou não acho eu acho que não foi um
dos meus pais esta máquina estava lá
algo porque é um tio algum primo e
deixar lá em casa com a máquina barata e
eu resolvi gravar esta máquina para
presta viagem talvez para tentar
distrair daquilo que acontecer e para
isolar um bocadinho do mundo os meus
pais e ficar no meu próprio ccbb que
escrevi eu nunca estava o fotógrafo bem
por ali mas comprei um rolo e ovelha
máquina e foi com essa máquina que eu
tirei esta atitude difícil
esta fotografia foi uma delas que veio
não significa nava os meus pais param
alguns álbum piquenique uma coisa do
gênero e outro foi um marco na estrada
enquanto um carro passava também terei
esta simples é na altura o vantagem
muito cedo a chefe da manhã é coisa que
acho que nunca mais aconteceu desde
então e e futuras a estes pescadores
estavam a volta das letras e treinar
ainda esta é a minha favorita
qualquer um de vocês acha que é uma
daquelas edifício foram tirar porque
simplesmente não tem cargo no quintal
enquanto tiravam a máquina do saco é o
que parece ferimentos mas foi esta
fotografia como usou muita televisão é a
emoção
aqui o que eu poderia fazer pela
primeira vez de olhar para uma coisa que
eu tinha feito e me intrigou entre como
porque esta imagem não dava para fazer
outra coisa qualquer porque essa imagem
foi tirada enquanto os pais estavam
fazendo de fato um piquenique cadastrava
e enquanto nós estávamos lá a fazer
piquenique é eu tinha uma imagem parece
literalmente o fim do mundo
parece uma coisa diz focada para ficar
aí parece comum desapareceu e que essa
lista é um bando de destroços o que o
faz uma imagem banal mas é o que eu
fiquei intrigado com esta imagem que
durante semanas e semanas porque os meus
pais compraram uma máquina vai comprar
uma máquina de 101 máquinas mais baratas
do mercado máquina russa marcas n
e essa marca essa marca não essa máquina
nunca mais me abandonou
durante todos os restos do talvez
durante quatro anos eu tive essa máquina
é que
sempre que em todo o lado onde eu ia pra
chuchu é para para os encontros com os
amigos à noite quando ia sair
essa máquina nunca mais me abandonou e
essas foram as chefias que terei com
essa máquina imensa sacrifício de
milhares e milhares de fiéis ao longo
destes anos esta é uma delas
esta é outra eu passava pelos citizens e
ia tirando fotos esta é outra esta e
outras outras imagens que tinha 16 17
anos e eu ia vendo as coisas e elas é
que o que eu percebi é que o mundo
quando tinha máquina fotográfica nas
minhas mãos
eu mudava eu não eu já não era só uma
pessoa que estava no mundo mas era uma
pessoa que estava sistematicamente para
ver o que o mundo dava o que o sítio
onde estavam que o que significava pra
mim eu topava tudo aquilo é e todos os
chiques de todas as pessoas porque eu
passava eu sou muito tímido e tive que
deixar de ser prefeitura para essas
pessoas vão estar perto delas e estar
nestes locais trouxe uma coisa
radicalmente diferente pra mim eu
continuei com isso ao longo de toda a
minha vida essas fichas que tira aí nos
últimos dois anos
é exatamente a mesma coisa o mesmo em
força que vou alcançar essas fotografias
é exatamente é mesmo continuou ao longo
destes anos todos é fazer com que o psi
é o mesmo assunto ou seja olhar para o
mundo de uma forma muito mais atento do
que eu fazia anteriormente
não planeio essa estrutura física é a
máquina sempre comigo e eu tal como no
início eu vou fazer o exatamente a mesma
forma é que eu aprendi com isto foi o
que eu aprendi no fundo para a minha
música como tendo uma dessas imagens
existir
eu preciso pegar eu preciso pegar pelo
menos 300 400 imagens a ter uma imagem
destas que eu gosto que o que eu acho
que funciona comigo e funciona com a
forma como eu estou a ver o mundo
naquela altura e descobrir se também da
música que falhara de facto melhor sobre
a forma de chegar ao sítio onde
efetivamente quero para cada canção que
eu gosto de fazer
há pelo menos 45 50 saem tensões na
gaveta
nunca viram nem nunca foram alguns dizia
porque porque são março são péssimas
para eu voltar então a primeira pergunta
que este humilde fazem como o tpresso no
mundo da música não faça mais querida e
continuo sem saber e que o que mais me
intriga não é porque este humilde que
essas pessoas querem atingir o sucesso é
porque elas não querem fracassar porque
elas estão tão vidrado na idéia de fazer
uma coisa vença em vez de estarem
preocupadas em fazer algo que por
simplesmente de um prazer imenso sem
sequer pela profunda que ela está aí
porque ela tem que ceder de uma forma
tão brilhante porque assim tão
importante
elvis presley é um dos meus heróis em
eu eu fui dos espetáculos onde começou a
cantar por é porque o diretor do teatro
e que não tinha talento
silva é um dos jogadores mais conhecidos
do mundo e e eu não consigo entrar na
escola do cinema teatro da califórnia 13
no sítio não tinha médias entrar
charlie chaplin os homens mais lindos do
mundo os primeiros filmes deu foram
rejeitados por todas as grandes
companhias do debut por serem demasiado
absurdos e sem querer comparar o
movimento com essas três pessoas reais
também o chaves foto de carreira foram
recusadas por todas as editoras no país
porque o cantava em inglês ao porquê
porque as músicas eram demasiado lenta
só porque eram opel era um chato só
porque ela mesma iria não faça mais
careta mas sei que fomos à sistemática e
vendo que todas essas vitórias e nick
estão ao longo de todo este todo este
percurso durante esses três anos em que
em que esta banda foi rejeitada eu nem
por uma única vez pensar em usar como
algumas editoras nos diziam que não
devia mudar estimular aquilo que eu acho
que surpreendia no facto de as pessoas
não quererem
trabalhar conosco não veria que o que
era não verem teve uma ideia de frente
que poderia sim ganhar ou não mas que
era um risco que era um risco que era
que vale a pena tomar ao longo destes
dez anos eu nunca pensar e nós nunca
vamos atingir o sucesso não é o sucesso
que atraía nunca foi nunca quis foi um
sucesso uma coisa boa pra não queria
mais nos divertimos e que e que tivessem
que fazer
o significativo para cada um nós e que
estivéssemos num sítio onde efetivamente
cria está o sucesso era uma coisa
efetivamente nunca pensámos que aconteça
e eu acho que é que o uso assumiu a
forma de olhar para o mundo e um forma
de olhar mesmo para a própria banda dos
jogos fora e não há 11 jogos de sucesso
é que havia um prazer muito grande em
absorver o mundo e transformá lo em
outra coisa não sabia me atingir um
sucesso perante os nossos passos mais
pra nós próprios para mim é a minha
realização pessoal e para os contar para
acabaram com a minha história eu queria
apresentar destas duas pessoas realmente
nenhum de vocês sabem quem eu sou eu
próprio não ser vivo a r 10
chamam-se e ray já a banda inglesa
eu não conhecia muito bem mas eu na
altura eu estava isto foi há muitos anos
atrás
em 96 97 e estava morando na residência
de estudantes ea minha conta do fórum
era gigantesca lisboa e não tinha
dinheiro pra pagar
eu fui a secretaria desta residência do
estudante estava discutindo com essa
briga que já acontecia há muito tempo
sobre a forma de pagar esta conta sem
ponto na forma mais limpa em prestações
assim bastava falar pra mim eu estava
ouviu estava a ouvir
estava vendo um colega aqui ao meu lado
estávamos a falar e rádio que estava em
cima da mesa uma canção cheers começa a
passar e eu acho que é a razão pela qual
houve essa canção com tanta atenção tem
a ver com esse percurso com essa idéia
de olhar para o mundo
uma tenta como fiz com fotografia de
olhar pra eu de uma forma
sistematicamente interessantes e ariel
estava a falar pra mim ou para ir de
ouvir e conhecer e ouvir este tema e foi
aí que houve o tema é amplo espectro da
igreja e penso eu vou fazer uma opção de
sistema e fiz essa opção e foi a solução
contra tudo e contra todos que fez com
que o chauás fora images em e que
tivesse algum sucesso para os seus
passos aqui era uma coisa nunca pensava
em mim pra acabar vou temos esse tipo de
16 anos há 15 anos que eu tenho aqui em
cima da mota que estava em cima da moto
ao lançar para onde é que vai uma
pequena idéia lançada ainda que o mundo
é um filho que tem tudo para lhe dar se
estiver de olhos muito abertos e que eu
tenho pra dizer hoje a saúde no mundo
das idéias nada fixo reforma de
absorvemos do mundo e viu entendermos
desenvolvermos de alguma forma da nossa
forma pessoal é de olharmos para o mesmo
muito muito atentamente e 600 700
pessoas a 700 maneiras diferentes de ver
este sítio a 700 maneiras diferentes de
olhar dos instrumentos que está a
acontecer
absorvo não façam deu o vosso momento e
depois ponho cá para fora e acho que
tudo correrá bem
é isso